absent some absolutely
unexpected turn of events you know the
kraken falls down from heaven or
something
it's looking like the biden
administration
everyone believes this to be the case
already
the media are feeling emboldened big
tech in particular is feeling emboldened
big tech twitter donald trump's favorite
uh media social media platform twitter
is already saying
that after election day they may ban
president trump from twitter
they've wanted to do it while he's in
office but they're in a bit of a bind
because they allow the ayatollah
khamenei
in iran to tweet and talk about the
destruction of israel and whatever he
wants
and they don't have any problem with
that but they death to america whatever
that that's fine but they realized it
would look like a double standard
if you allowed the ayatollah to stay on
twitter
but took the duly elected president of
the united states off twitter so instead
what have they done you know you've been
seeing this
they just add a fact check to every
single one of trump's tweets at this
point
he says i had a good omelet for
breakfast this claim is disputed
official sources dispute this claim yeah
i had three eggs in my omelette official
jim acosta says he might have only had
two and a half or maybe four
fact check so they're going to get rid
of it
after january 20th they say that they
will
very possibly kick donald trump off of
twitter why
because so long as president trump stays
on twitter he's the second most followed
politician after barack obama
barack obama was the first president
during the age of twitter
and personally pretty popular himself
if you allow president trump to remain
on twitter then he still has a voice
that can break through
beyond the mainstream media beyond the
gatekeepers who are now going to try to
make everything very very boring
you're going to see their ratings
decline trump has been phenomenal for
for the mainstream media's ratings
doesn't matter he's undercutting the
liberal establishment project
and so they're going to try to cut him
out as best they possibly can
i'm sure twitter makes it fair i don't
really know how twitter monetizes their
platform beyond the advertisements and
selling your data
probably to china but they are
i'm sure twitter could make more money
and have more engagement on their
platform
if they allowed president trump to stay
on and still
they will oppose it because they want to
get back to boring
business as usual but it does appear
to be coming to an end you know i have
held out hope longer
than just about anybody in conservative
politics i've
held i don't think we should concede the
race early
i don't think we should do any of those
i don't think it's
overturning constitutional norms to
question
the results of an election that
obviously had many many many
many irregularities and sometimes
outright criminal behavior
in places i don't think there's anything
wrong about that
but it does appear to be coming to an
end bill barr attorney general
whom i've had the privilege of
interviewing the honey badger is
uh is leaving the trump administration
some people are a little upset with bill
barr right now
because barr did not come out and
overtly challenge the results of the
election uh
one thing i will say and i think it's
when we're trying to figure out what do
we think of the bar era at the doj
president trump is being very
complimentary toward bill barr as he
leaves
donald trump has not always been very
complimentary toward his leaving
attorneys general you remember what he
did to poor jeff sessions
and to other cabinet members but
he says quote just had a very nice
meeting with attorney general bill barr
at the white house
our relationship has been a very good
one he has done an outstanding
job as per bill's letter he will be
leaving just before christmas to spend
the holidays with his family
deputy attorney general jeff rosen an
outstanding person will become acting
attorney general highly respected
richard donahue
will be taking over the duties of deputy
a.g thank you to all so he's being very
kind to
to bill barr and bill barr by the way in
his resignation letter
was extraordinarily complimentary to
president trump says i'm greatly honored
that you called on me to serve your
administration the american people once
again as attorney general
don't forget he had already been
attorney general during the bush one
administration
i'm proud to have played a role in the
many successes and unprecedented
achievements you have delivered for the
american people
your record is all the more historic
because you accomplished it in the face
of the relentless
and implacable resistance your 2016
victory speech in which you reached out
to your opponents and called for working
together
for the benefit of the american people
was immediately met with a partisan
onslaught against you
in which no tactic no matter how abusive
and deceitful
was out of bounds that the nadir of this
campaign was
the effort to [ __ ] if not oust your
administration this is just
there's a great resignation letter
basically saying you are great
your opponents are dirt bags and i'm
sorry it's coming to an end and so
i look at this not as a prescriptive
matter billboard saying yeah we need the
trump administration to end
step down concede he's basically saying
no you got done dirty buddy
but it's over anyway because that's
that's the constitutional system
so you lose guys like bill barr who talk
about the absolute
onslaught of partisan trash that they've
heaped on you
you lose people like hayley mcinerney
who just go out every day with a nice
long whip
and just start whipping the press with
her searing wonderful rhetoric
and facts and logic yeah it's been
really enjoyable
now what are we getting well president
uh elect
president-elect joe biden is naming
people to his cabinet
and what are the big exciting picks what
are the ones that are really oh man here
it comes
for good or for real pete buttige
as transportation secretary this news is
so
boring and lame i think i'm going to
fall asleep just reading it